good evening welcome to the special
forum tonight I'm banking Union in
Europe prospects and challenges my name
is Jean Jean way I'm a professor at
Columbia Business School this event is
jointly organised by the Economics
Department program and economic research
and the business schools jerome chasing
institute of international business as
all of you know that European Union has
agreed to start a banking Union
sometimes sometimes soon the details
have yet to be worked out but as
agreement about a single supervisory
mechanisms and single resolution
authorities and role of ECB in
supervising banks many more important
questions are still to be determined so
what are the issues still need to be
worked out and what is the likely shape
of the new banking Union in Europe how
would financial markets and monetary
policies respond to that and how would
those development affect financial
sector in the US and rest of the world
for insight on these important questions
we will tend to our two very prominent
speakers former policymakers farmer
Europe Victor Gaspar is the former
finance minister of Portugal having
served from twenty eleven to twenty
thirteen he was previously directed
general for the ECB and head of a bureau
of economic policy advisers at a
European Commission is currently with
the bank of Portugal athanasius of
Vanitas is a professor of the practice
of global economics and management at
MIT Sloan School he served as governor
of the Central Bank of Cyprus from may
2007 to may 2012 as governor he oversaw
the introduction of a euro into his
country and subsequently service member
of the governing council of the ECB from
2008 to 2000-2012 prior to his
appointment as governor
served as senior advisor at Federal
Reserve Board the panel will be
moderated by our own professor ricardo
reis so i will tend to professor Rees
for now right thank you very much engine
so we're going to try to do this as
close as we can to debate and so what I
agreed was that so each one was going to
each one of the speakers first feature
than athanasius will speak for about six
or seven minutes with an introduction
and then I'll ask a few questions and
then I'll open it to the floor to for
questions that you may have so start
with Peter please thanks Ricardo the way
I like to tell this story comes very
naturally to me because I can start when
I became a finance minister in June 2011
one of the things that marked the
beginning of my tenure as soon as
Minister was the informal meeting of
ministers of finance in Poland during
the Polish presidency you may recall the
dead a particular meeting of the ekka
theme and the Eurogroup was attended by
Timothy Geithner Timothy Geithner
Secretary of Treasury was invited to
come to speak about global developments
and how the crisis in the euro area was
impacting the US and global economy the
view that was widely publicized at the
time was that in the view of the US
Treasury the crisis of the euro area was
the single most important factor of
risks developments in the global economy
and if you look at the international
press you see that the international
press was dominated between say jun 2011
until july 2012 it was dominated by
headlines about the possible
fragmentation of the euro area and that
was a
a catastrophical risk that was not only
dominating events in Europe was also the
most important development in the global
economy now the things have improved
quite substantially after the summer
about 2012 and the reasons are basically
of three kinds first of all the
countries that were mostly under stress
adjusted and made a remarkable
adjustment effort that if you do look at
those countries as an average you see
that the countries have been able to
regain competitiveness eliminate current
account deficits in general increase
exports quite substantially and
eliminate the need to finance themselves
with the rest of the world so national
adjustment has been progressing fast
national adjustment does reflect first
and foremost the political will of
national governments to do what is
necessary to maintain full participation
in the euro area and determination to
achieve successful adjustment in the ER
that's the first dimension the second
dimension is a political will at the
level of the head of state and
government of the euro area and of the
European Union to preserve the euro area
and the European Union as a political
project that is very clear from what was
done in June June 2012 and there is a
very influential blueprint
that calls for a banking Union fiscal
Union economic union and political union
of this the most operational dimension
and the one that has more immediate
impact on the current crisis is a
banking Union and I've been arguing
consistently that we need to broaden the
concept of a banking Union to have a
fully robust financial union that can
withstand shocks like the crisis that
we're facing and the third element is
the the euro area needed a selection
mechanism that would exclude the
possibility of self-fulfilling bad
equilibria taking hold and that was
precisely what was achieved with the
announcement by the President of the
European Central Bank Mario Draghi in
July 2012 with the whatever it takes
within our mandate speech in London and
then the announcement of the outright
monetary transactions program of the ECB
in September so at this point in time we
are in a situation where banking Union
is well on track to be operational
market sentiment has improved quite
substantially and Europe and the euro
area are definitely not mentioned in the
list of relevant risks for the global
economy and with this short introduction
you can see that I'm the optimist in
this debate so I have to turn now to the
pessimist which is my partner in this
debate at the ratha ravi needed thanks
Vito for for this wonderful setting up
of the event
it and also regarded thanks for actually
bringing us here I think I'm being being
in this in this room and having Italy
all around us is very appropriate since
Italy is one of the most important links
that are going to determine over the
next 10 or more years whether the the
Euro construction that we know it will
manage to survive or not and first let
me let me let me speak a couple of
minutes by first agreeing with with with
reader on the great improvement
interception that we have experienced in
the last year and a half since july of
2012 and where we are right now in terms
of market perceptions you know very new
york city's going to be sensitive and
aware of what people around us believe
about the future of the euro area i
agree that the situation appears to be
much more stable right now and clearly
markets globally show incredible
complacency with regard to the risks
emanating from from the euro area and I
I think we need to give a lot of credit
to central banks for for this I'd like
to start with that first a lot of credit
to the ECB for removing the tension with
the announcement of the omt in July
thousand twelve this modern drag is
remarked that the ACB would do whatever
it takes within its mandate in order to
to stabilize the situation and then the
September of 2012 actual decision that's
one element the other element you may
wonder why our markets are doing even
better the last few months I think we
need to thank all of us Europeans we
need to thank the
the Federal Reserve for the tensions it
created in emerging markets since last
summer those tensions are wonderful for
us because they have taken the spotlight
of of the euro area and investors in
globally now say hey you know where we
had a half a dozen euralia member states
that looked like terrible cases of
emerging markets they are not really as
terrible in the in the spectrum of
emerging markets as we thought before
there will be better than than the
typical emerging market economy and this
has held a lot reverse some of the flows
and unfair they've stabilized the the
situation but let me but let me then
turn into what my assessment of the
situation right now is and what my
concerns are about about Europe I think
we can all agree that the construction
of the euro as it was pushed together in
the Maastricht Treaty and implemented
starting 1999 was a mistake at that time
I was in the United States and I know
very well that the that the consensus
among US based economies was that it
would be a mistake to proceed with this
experiment because there were too many
gaps too many questions and it was
unclear how these gaps would be a
would-be answer to how these questions
would be addressed if something wrong
that happened as a European I at the
time I shared the view of the optimists
in in Europe that suggested that the
European project as we know it started
really 60 years ago almost now this is
not this is not just since the creation
of the euro it has been evolving and it
has been making tremendous progress in
building a unified Europe step by step
and it was always an incomplete project
and the
the whole notion and the whole optimus
was based that in the past in this
almost 60 year period every time there
was a crisis a challenger to the
European governments the European
governments that were part of the
project would work together
cooperatively find the solution move
forward depend the European Union idea
and improve Europe in that regard so it
was assumed or hope you can pick
whichever one you you want that if
anything went wrong with the
construction of the Euro the same
process would would take over and there
would have there would be a cooperative
solution that would further tip and the
the euro area now what we have
experienced in the last four years from
slightly different angles but both of us
have experienced this is that is that
this hope or assumption was really
incorrect what we have seen in my
interpretation since the beginning of
the euro area crisis is a situation of
great animosity in Europe it really
started going downhill from late
2008-2009 when the government in some
Member States decided that it was not
really appropriate to try to find a
solution to the emerging problem that
would be good for Europe as a whole that
it would be a better approach to have
each member state of the euro area
toggle than difficult is already merging
on their own and is really led to
tensions and some examples and
unfortunately i have seen examples where
governments were actively trying to push
the losses from the crisis whenever
there is a crisis we have losses on to
the citizens of other member states in
the in the year
area and this is what really worries me
about the european project i'm now
watching this evolved from the united
states the united states had a similar
crisis in 2008 has nine and during the
first two years of the other of the
global crisis we've seen the response in
the US and europe was the same the
critical difference was that in the
united states we had a single federal
government at a single central bank
single congress darling washington you
may disagree with and decisions they've
taken but they've taken decisions trying
to minimize the damage for the country
as a whole if I contrast that with what
I've seen in Europe in Europe we have
had a number of governments in the euro
area where we really have the the other
problem with the common currency is
tying us together in a very
counterproductive way we have 17 18
governments fighting it out against each
other with nobody in the room having the
objective to adopt solutions for for
Europe that would be minimizing the cost
for the year end as a whole so that's
the setup I want to I want to I want to
give you with because I do worry that we
are not headed in the right direction I
I would agree with with video on another
point jun 2012 was a critical moment in
the in the crisis the euro area member
states met there was a european council
meeting this is the meaning of the heads
of states and governments in Europe and
believe it was in Brussels the
particular meeting and this is where
they agreed in principle to to form a
banking Union which is the current topic
we have we have today that was one of
the critical elements for it using the
tensions the tensions are up to the
point have been identified as a
so-called Doom loop that essentially
kills the state and the banks of the
state because they are interdependent to
each other the idea and this is what the
leaders say
Europe said was that a banking Union if
probably created would have eliminated
these links between the banks and the
sovereigns and held Europe advanced
unfortunately I do not agree with with
vidura's readers assessment that that we
are moving the right direction this in
this process the government's really in
my reading of the decisions have been
taken since jun 2012 have been moving
backwards and we had in december of last
of last year is very very negative
decision for europe which essentially
was to ask the ECB to continue with the
preparation to take over as the
supervisor of banks in Europe this is
one element one of the important
elements for the banking Union without
at the same time agreeing on a euro area
wide deposit guarantee and resolution
authority which are the two most
important elements for for the year area
and unfortunately there was a very
negative decision was up to in December
there was some hope that the European
governments would would have been able
to move forward in this in this regard
and as of December we know that the
banking Union s was envisioned in the
summer of thousand twelve is dead and
let me stop here very good so let me
start then with one question for you so
I mean what analysis expressed this
common view in Europe that it is doing
crisis that in the sense Europe moves
forward that it's in the response that
quite set the integration depends at the
same time you are pessimistic about well
at the same time we are going through a
crisis right now and it does seem that
the next step is exactly the banking
Union so to what extent do you think
that you agree with this idea first
Peter and a thematic that it is the
crisis at least the reforms and why do
you think why are you optimistic
Europe and click the right step this
time to solve the crisis in foreign or
are you pessimistic that the step right
now is not going to be taken and like
the history of Europe of the last
decades okay first of all I must say
that I was one of the negotiators of the
maastricht treaty so I think that the
monetary union has designed in the
treaty which was sign in the early 90s
was a concept which is appropriate for
Europe at that particular point in time
I fully agree with athanassios that it
was not a complete project but then
again in democracies and open societies
projects are never completed they all
our societies are work in progress the
second aspect that I very much want to
emphasize is that Europe tange as
athanasius as a matter of fact
emphasized to progress from crisis to
crisis and in terms of my professional
career I have seen basically three
cycles of crisis in Europe in the 1980s
in the early 1980s there was a socialist
government in France that pursued
expansionary budgetary policies after
the election of hasami teja as president
of France in that context the French
franc was under pressure inside the
exchange mechanic exchange rate
mechanism of the European monetary
system there was a turning of policies
in France
in the direction of what they called
competitive dis inflation deflation
competitive of in French and in that
context immediately after this
turnaround of policies in France there
was a French German consensus on the way
forward for Europe and that led to a big
impulse in European integration that led
to the single market program and
eventually to the launching of the
process of monetary unification now in
the 90s again and I was at that point in
time already active in European matters
there was a very important crisis in the
exchange rate mechanism of European
monetary system in 1992 1993 in August
nineteen ninety three different Frank
was under tremendous pressure it was at
that point the general view that no way
under this turmoil one could advance
towards a monetary unification but again
there was a possibility to generate a
French German consensus and monetary
union took off as forecasted as as has
agreed politically on the first of June
on the first of January 1999 now at this
point in time the ingredients that I saw
in the first two examples I gave you are
in place that is quite a substantive
progress was achieved in Europe the
political will to go forward is very
strong they have been some tensions
involving the conduct of policies in
France there has been a turnaround in
the policy orientation in France and my
understanding is that
the French and the German government are
very active finding a consensual path
forward which is exactly the way things
work in Europe we have a common track
and then a consensus involving France
and Germany makes it operational and
therefore defines the path following
that saw what I would expect to see
happening in the very near future and
that's why I'm optimistic replying
positively to the question you posed
regard so let me try to describe why I
do not quite share that that view and
what's different about the euro that was
not there before the creation of the of
the year regarding coming together and
resolving cooperatively a problem like
the problems that we don't describe
materialize before the year is different
in a couple of of respect but one of
them is is the following by by tying
together the financial and most
importantly than banking component of
the financial systems in the euro area
with a single currency very important
tools that member state governments had
in order to manage their domestic
economy disappear this increases the
leverage of whichever governments happen
to be perceived as strong during a
crisis and this was the first crisis we
have had over with this element when you
increase the leverage of the government
that is perceived to be a strong in a
setup like this you risked creating a
non cooperative behavior where some
governments may actually use the
construction of the euro in a way that
may create tremendous losses for other
countries now give you an example of
that
I agree with video on the importance of
France and Germany agreeing in principle
on a comment line for anything to be
achieved in the euro area simply because
together they are almost two-thirds of
the of the euro area so in one of the
main in all of the most important
blunders and during this crisis we had
this walk on the beach in in Deauville
in October of 2010 between the president
of France and the Chancellor of Germany
and that was a pivotal moment in the
crisis when those two governments
decided that it would be a good idea to
inject credit risk in euro area
governments and it's true they are great
on the same on the same line they did
not have her take into account that by
injecting credit risk in your area
governments this was the so-called PSI
concept a private sector involvement the
idea was that if any government faced
liquidity problems in the euro area the
the other you remember stage would first
require haircut on the debt and then
decide whether there would be alone made
to the country completely turning upside
down the traditional I'm a framework on
on this so add that decision that a few
weeks later caused the collapse of
Ireland and of course the consequences
of that decision on Ireland were
completely ignored and that's the kind
interpretation for taking that that
decision and if we did not have the euro
as a construction the Irish government
would have been a much better position
to defend the interests of the of their
own country if they were faced with such
an unfortunate decision taken by
by the French and German government is
just one of the examples of what is
different now than it was before tying
the banking industry actually increases
the leverage of those countries that
happen to be perceived strong doesn't
matter which one is in any period it was
a particular set of countries in this
particular crisis it could have been a
different set of countries it's just
that then decision-making framework is
is one that was setting us up for a
crisis like that in the in the euro area
and at the end of the day we ended up
not having governments that would show a
sufficiently strong spirit of
cooperation or really respect for the
European ideals to find a better
solution may get into Jack absolutely to
remarks on two very specific points but
before doing that I should say that
Athanasius is one of my favorite
economies and I always learned a lot
from athanasius so it's a slightly
embarrassing for me to be in this
confrontational mode but the refined
design this you know it was my fault she
liked it it's the rules of the game v200
I go back a long time you know say so
what are you doing to us but anyway you
did say something ethanol is that I
believe is not correct which is the
following you claimed that the symmetry
that we see between creditor and debtor
countries in the current crisis is
something which is new in the context of
the new of the euro area that's actually
not true i believe the fundamental point
about his symmetry between creditor and
debtor countries is a point that was
done by cannes in the very first book he
published on the Indian currency and
financing
1907 and he was emphasizing dia symmetry
between creditor and debtor countries at
the time of the negotiations of Bretton
Woods and I believe i saw wonderful
quote by canes in the paper by Guillermo
Calvo recently and that's by the way the
reason I found these two quotes from
games and the ax symmetry between
creditor and debtor countries is present
in all the examples I gave now in the
early 80s the French were very much
complaining about the symmetry in the
adjustment mechanism inside the European
monetary system and they were in a sense
complaining politically about the
predominance of the Bundesbank in the
context of monetary Arrangements are in
Europe the argument was again repeated
in the early 90s so this symmetry was
really a part of the process and in
Europe we have this element of
confrontation but then a cooperative
collective action is agreed and
implemented that's what happened in the
80s that's what happened in the 90s that
has been happening in the context of
this crisis a lot has been achieved at
national and European level and the
process is going to continue to be
successful now I had two points to make
this was the first point and the second
I forgot but but let me let me interject
that and that would give you a chance to
to remember the second point that I
agree with you that there is always the
asymmetry do you describe between the
stronger and weaker i'm going to call
them stronger a weekend with your
country's in this and i agree with that
what i said is that the construction of
the euro created a mechanism that
leverages the exploitation potential by
the stronger countries on the with your
country's take the example adjust i just
mentioned when you mention before the 20
years ago had the 22 years ago now we
had the Iran crisis the weaker countries
at that point in time could actually
entertain the idea of devaluing their
currency that was very important makin
it for a for stabilization I was
available to them that was costly to the
stronger countries and that reduced the
leverage that the stronger countries had
in coming up with a better solution this
was not available during this crisis and
as a result the possibility for
exploiting the imbalances was much much
greater and in addition we have the
other element that the common monetary
policy big basie be in the middle is
binding us together in a very
counterproductive a mother for fourth
for this for these elements and let me
since this about the banking Union make
make a point to link it back to the
banking Union why where we concerned
about Spain two years ago why was pain
experiencing tremendous deposit outflows
for a long time well simply because
anybody who would have been concerned in
Spain about the ability of the Spanish
government to provide temporary
assistance in Europe to a spanish bank
could simply go up in a bank account
anywhere else in the euro area at a very
very minimal cost and secure his
position
that was there because of the common
currency and this is something that was
good if it was not exploited that we
have the common courtesy working
everywhere with freedom of capital
everywhere but it was bad if it were
exploited for example already in 2012 we
knew that it was a good idea to set up a
banking Union meaning having common
supervision a common deposit guarantee
let me know got the resolution because
if we were to author a common deposit
guarantee to all the positives in all
member states of the euro area then the
Spanish depositors would not need to
worry about the link and the strength of
their government and we would not be
having the deposit flight out of out of
the country so we knew these things and
the question is how can that the
government did not actually agree to set
up the banking Union two years ago three
years ago why is it the case that some
governments continue to object to
setting up a meaningful of common
deposit guarantee in the year area when
there are many explanations that one
explanation is that the construction of
the year is such that as long as you do
not create that common deposit guarantee
you can create and maintain a
competitive advantage for the banking
industry you're under state and this
goes back to what I mentioned before the
uncooperative behavior of trying to see
how much can we grab and keep in our in
our member state and how much we can
take away from it from here from the
others what is going on in Europe the
last few years i can describe in a
different way by comparing it to the
united states the united states don't
have a model banking union where the
Federal Reserve is essentially the
supervisor this is the role that the ECB
will be taking at the end of the year
and the FDIC is the agency that provides
the deposit guarantee and also the
resolution authority
in all states in in the country you do
not have the situation in the United
States where if say California is in
terrible fiscal mess perhaps you have to
start issuing script who knows perhaps
nobody starts perhaps nobody trusts the
state government it's not the case that
there will be questions about the safety
of deposits in California and the cost
of funding for in business operating in
California this is because we have a
true banking Union by contrast in the
euro area we knew that we could have had
a similar setup but we still cannot
create one if we created something like
that then the Spanish depositors two
years ago would have would have been
saved small businesses would have been
able to borrow money at the same rates
that that the small businesses of equal
credit worthiness are able to borrow
money in the industry anger countries we
would have been out of this crisis but
think about the political dynamics that
cannot let that happen kanden
governments in the stronger states who
happen to be in a stronger position
right now afford politically to give up
a tremendous competitive advantage that
some of the interest in their member
states have right now and give that away
to the member states that have citizens
who are European citizens but who as
voters have nothing to do with our
elections it's a tough nut to crack
let me let me well I'll let you
interject but let me steer in a certain
direction look SWOT analysis is said how
he believes that the current banking
unit is ultimately incomplete because it
misses the positive insurance and
resolution authority and also that even
in the small decisions that there is too
much of a non cooperative behavior but
you at the start that talk that not only
we should walk towards banking Union but
even financial unit which seemed more
ambitious that's what extent do you
think that we should be married to your
extent therefore drew athanasius
concerns make you worry about that in
that if anything thank you even be more
incomplete and why are you optimistic
they will reach there given those before
I tackle your question which is indeed a
central question I i want to make two
very brief remarks i remember my second
remark which is about the fact that in
the context of the exchange rate
mechanism of european monetary system
the doctrine which was broadly
consensual is that by fixing the
exchange rate the central banks of most
participants in the mechanism would gain
credibility for price stability by
basically mimicking the policy the
monetary policy of the very credible
Bundesbank now this doctrine was
accepted in most countries it was a
politically very relevant and so it was
very costly politically for a national
government to propose a sharp
devaluation of the currency and
typically the reason why we had such a
turmoil and such a turbulence in
exchange markets was precisely because
given this political cost governments
would postpone and postpone and postpone
the decision to realign one of the best
statements that does show that in fact
the functioning of the exchange rate
mechanism was very close
to monetary union is the perspective of
the Dutch central bank at that point in
time the governor was Vin Diesel bird
who became the first president of the
european central bank and vim doesn't
work said indeed we are fully autonomous
in our interest rate decisions we can
postpone and interest rate move by 30
minutes or thereabouts so the autonomy
that at analysis is talking about is
mostly an illusion if one is playing the
game by these rules and those were the
rules that were accepted by all members
or almost all members of the exchange
rate mechanism the second aspect is that
sometimes when we look at progress were
very impatient one of the things that
I've been working at is at the process
of the construction of the US banking
system and US financial system so i
started with the actions by alexander
hamilton in the late 18th century now
the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation was created if i'm not
mistaken 1933 so it took about 140 years
from the start of the process to a
situation where the system resembles
what Athena zio's is describing now
there were many crisis in the United
States during those 140 years and there
were even instances of financial
fragmentation very much like what we
have seen in Europe so it was hard
working United States as well right in
our case I think that we're progressing
definitely must much faster than the
historical United States now coming to
the banking and financial you
and the process of building it I believe
that ethanol and I agree that the
banking Union must have three
fundamental elements the first one is
the single supervisory mechanism that's
the responsibility for Banking
Supervision which is now in the hands of
the European Central Bank that's
basically something which has been
politically achieved it is being
implemented very fast in Frankfurt the
single supervisory mechanism is being
built then there is bank resolution bank
resolution is working progress there is
a legal document on banking resolution
which is now consensual there is a very
important gap which is working progress
that has to do with the European
backstop to that resolution mechanism
the third element is as athanasius also
said we must have a European Deposit
Insurance Scheme and again we need to
have a European backstop to ensure that
there is not the connection that
Athanasius was talking about between
country risk and banking risk we need to
separate the two if not we don't have a
robust integrated financial system now
the point that I add to all of this is
that in history at least as far as my
reading goes a banking system does not
operate in a vacuum it must be
complemented by financial market and
those financial markets have to go have
to be fully integrated so that the
system the financial system in
euro area is a robust system that has
multiple channels multiple
inter-linkages that can operate in a
robust way and distress and we need debt
robustness because what we have seen in
this crisis is that the financial
mechanism not only did not help
absorbing the crisis but as a matter of
fact they amplify the crisis we had
financial fragmentation during the
crisis and we must make sure that that
will not happen when the next one comes
and we will have some next crisis and
therefore we cannot have a narrow scheme
of financial integration we need to have
a multiple channel based integration
network and so we need banking Union and
a broader financial union that basically
means the integration of financial
markets let me also although you're
certainly happy to retort to exactly
what Peter said let me also resist you
if you've talked a lot about the
symmetry of power across countries what
the crisis are certainly was stronger
hitting in some other very small
countries in Europe such as Greece
Ireland Portugal and Cyprus um do you
think that if the next crisis were to
hit Italy and since you brought up Italy
together would we have seen the same
dynamics where things would look very
different in terms of the ability to
cooperate it's given that it is such a
much larger country there and I'm going
to start answering that and waiting for
videos rebuttal by reminding you of the
earlier point I made about leverage that
a government has to protect its economy
is binding industry is businesses
relative to the governments of the other
countries size matters for that reason
so the fact that some of the relatively
smaller member states have been hit
where whereas other members day
appear to be just barely making it his
indulgence to this let me remind you
that we do have a player in this game
it's very interesting game quite unique
in the history of of of monetary affairs
and globally we have a player in this
game who can always innovate tools and
within its mandate who do whatever it
takes to salvage the the situation we
have a crisis let me remind you for
example that when we came not in 2012 in
2011 we had the big skier before the
summer of two thousand twelve was in
october november of 2011 after the heads
of states of europe and october 27
decided to impose something that ended
up being an eighty percent haircut on on
greek debt and while they kept insisting
and this is what the community said
Greece is unique trust us just trust us
everybody else will honor their debt
they created major major problems
immediately for a number of other member
states including the third largest
member states in their enduring the euro
area Italy and Italy was on the verge of
following the Irish experience well this
other player in the game at a time the
ECB decided that it could do something
about it and that was the time that you
had a couple of decisions with him a few
months a bad one that one was seen after
October we have what became known later
on as the wall of money just give as
much as much liquidity to any bank that
wishes to
have that liquidity just bring us
collateral you decide where the colada
is going to be Italian debt or something
else beyond design completely up to you
by as much liquidity as you wish just
come to us cheap money for three years
we'll do it and this is the sort of
policy innovation that you would not
have seen if a member state that is
worth only two percent of your area and
GDP I think Portugal and Greece were
about two percent of the euro and GDP or
smaller would get from this other player
in the in the ropes it's quite
indulgence to their to the game we're
observing I want to open it to the to
the audience so if people would like to
ask a question and get the session going
we have a microphone in the middle there
with you if you do speak please just say
your name and just your affiliation is
that people can't reject
I'm Padma Desai I'm the harriman
professor at Columbia University in the
Economics Department I have a question
and a comment on the question relates to
Mario Draghi's announcement in july two
thousand twelve whatever it takes and
let go on a very liberal monetary policy
amid cash in the European eurozone area
where there are some tensions with
German Chancellor and with bath central
bank of Germany the person in charge
there because the German leadership and
policy makers always worried about
inflation given the German experience so
that was my question are there any
tensions between the ECB leadership and
the German centre-back leadership the
second comment relates to I think I
often notice especially European policy
makers contrasting and comparing the
experience of the eurozone with that of
the United States saying of the United
States has a single currency a single
federal reserve and all that and yet it
had tensions for 140 years of
policymaking and so on I think a better
comparison would be with the countries
it is India with 15 major languages with
a vast cultural difference between the
north and the south of India and after
67 years of independence it has held
together with a single currency a single
Federal Reserve central government the
countries having
an election in may I speak as an
American because I have lived here for
50 years so my sensibilities are more
American but that I think is a better
example to draw from of how a country
with so much diversity linguistic
cultural policy making because Indian
states have enormous freedom to invite
foreign investment to make their own
budgets and so on it has held together
but I sometimes feel maybe European and
American policymakers don't want to draw
from the example of an emerging market
economy thank you so I was gonna get the
same order unless you so on India I
cannot really comment because I'm
profoundly ignorant about the
specificities of the Indian financial
system and implementation of monetary
policy in Europe but I was very
intrigued by by by your comment and so I
will try to find out I happened to i was
with the governor of the Central Bank of
India some three months ago and if I had
benefited from your comment before I
would have asked him probably we will
meet again and I will try to make sure
that I learned from the experience of
India that indeed looks like a very
diverse territorial unity and so from
that viewpoint resembles closer the
degree of diversity that we have in
Europe router to United States but
something that is very important to
emphasize is that the degree of autonomy
across the member states of the European
Union
is considerably bigger more profound
than what you see across the states of
the United States the United States is a
federation and the European Union is not
a federation is something that we would
characterize as a confederation not not
indeed a federation now when you think
about monetary policy and inflation
clearly in in the debate about mother
policy in Germany there are comments
about possible risks of inflation that
are much less frequency elsewhere in
Europe and concerns about too low
interest rates and the penalty that that
constitutes for pension funds for
example which is also a relatively rare
common part of it has of course to do
with what you said the memory of
hyperinflation in Germany but in some
instances the concerns about policy
matters in Germany seem to be weakly
correlated with concerns elsewhere in
Europe that is the European Commission
conducts regularly a survey called
eurobarometer and if you go around
Europe and see what is the most
important problem from the viewpoint of
the Portuguese Spanish friend and many
others the top problem is unemployment
but in in in Germany is excessive debt
they're concerning they're concerned
about the excessive accumulation of
public debt and when I saw that I was
really surprised but he does illustrate
the type of differences that you always
have when you have integration on the
Continental basis so I was also
intrigued by the comment and I was gonna
answer it by pointing out to to what
vidor said if you think about it the way
the way many Europeans would think about
the United States is that it's the
country that was built after the
Portuguese in the Irish and the Germans
and the Greeks in the English came and
somehow it seems to be working better
how come it's the same people of course
there are more people and there is
various this element of envy so this is
what this is one element but the other
element that's important is that we
study we study each other's history very
much so we can be making these
comparisons as as we go by and we do not
unfortunately the same gap in our
education we do not study in in s grade
and detail the the history of really all
of Asia we we just don't it's a gap in
our education that blinds us to to that
to that comment yet with regard to with
regard to the to the omt and and you
mentioned how the Chancellor might have
seen that policy first of all I will say
that the the announcement of the omt
Mario Draghi's statement identity and
then the year on decision in September
should not be interpreted as moving ECB
monetary policy to become more
accommodative and if anything since then
monetary policy in the Euro system has
become considerably tighter relative say
to the monetary policy of the of the
Federal Reserve one very easy metric
it's not a perfect metric that it's an
easy metric that can that can be used
for this comparison is to check the size
of the balance sheet since that was made
we had in September than December of of
2012 the Federal Reserve speeding up the
printing of easy money if you want to
describe it like that whereas if you
check the balance sheet of the of the
Euro system it has been declining
allowing that particular metric of
monetary conditions to tighten despite
the fact that the euro area was in a
severe recession and an inflation was
was not really projected to be at the
target so it wasn't deliberate decision
to be on the tight side which is you
know the in terms of assessing risk so
it wasn't easy monetary policy what was
it and why would anybody object what
recipe did with that decision was
essentially attract the attention of
market participants that it would be
dangerous to their health to bet against
the year it was just an implicit threat
and when you have increased threats like
that the question is where they are
credible or not and if they are credible
for how long they are credible and it
happened to be very effective in that
that threat was considered by a
sufficiently large number of markets
participants credible enough for long
enough to stabilize the system basically
do you have to do anything he just
created doubts about whether it was a
good idea to going to going against you
we don't even know if if it would have
worked if challenged and we still don't
know you don't know these things until
something is tested
and you have to take your bets as to
whether you would like something like
this to be tested after things
stabilized or not you might go into the
microphone the device the acoustics
little peculiar you might go to the
microphone yeah so why don't we then do
two questions in a row you Danielle and
then mark ok so I'm Daniel I'm a student
in the Economics Department and my
question is related to Professor to size
question went about tensions and to what
mr. Gaspar just said about the
eurobarometer polls so you both talked
about the previous erm crises is giving
us some potentially some insight about
how this banking Union negotiation might
go but I was just thinking that it seems
to me that something that might be quite
different this time is the degree of
public animosity and an anger in the in
the relevant countries we've seen huge
protests lots of public anger against
against austerity in the weaker
countries in the stronger countries a
sense of of anger as well at feeling
like they have to bail out the the poor
countries I would just want to know if
how you think this might complicate the
negotiations this this time around if
that could change the game mark hi mark
kingdon university trustee I just wanted
to ask the two gentlemen if you could
speculate on whether we'll ever see a
national banking Union with a full FDIC
which will think would be a good idea
and if so when might this occur
okay um Daniel I am much more optimistic
I've a very much more benign reading of
the political situation in Europe in the
following sense although the debate has
been very lively and indeed we have
witnessed protests on austerity programs
throughout Europe in general the
national political systems have been
able to withstand this very intense
political debate while standing to a
very large degree unchanged that is look
at my own country Portugal there has
been an intense debate but the
constellation of political forces that
we have in Portugal in 2014 is very much
what we had in 2011 the players are same
the positions have evolved because
reality has evolved but to wait the
political debate in the country
structured is broadly unchanged and if
you go around Europe that is basically
the case in the vast majority of
countries you do have one or two odd
exceptions to this rule now in the
context of the next European elections
it is likely that my remark will prove
compatible with some radicalization
of the representative elected to the
European Parliament but at just an
example of political polarization under
a crisis and I don't see that as being
qualitatively different from what we
have seen previously in Europe that is
the reason why the political situation
in the early 80s and the early 90s does
not look dramatic of to us now he's
simply because we know that the story
went it ended well but the process was
quite messy in particular in the 80s
people in Europe were very pessimistic
about national politics and they were
even more pessimistic about European
politics at that point in time European
politics were characterized as euros
chlorotic and that was a reasonably
consensual qualification that was made
about European politics we simply forget
we don't care much about what happened
in the eighties now the question about
banking Union and national banking union
is a very very interesting in particular
because in the question the euro area is
being qualified as a nation now I don't
think that we are going to have the euro
area or the European Union as a nation
during my lifetime I'm a very firm
believer in the fundamental political
principle of the primacy of the National
dimension of politics and I believe that
will stay but I do believe that this
primacy of the National dimension of
politics is compatible with the building
of a banking Union in the
euro area and deep banking and financial
integration in the European Union in
line with the single market I believe
that in that context we will have a
European resolution mechanism backed by
a European backstop facility and we'll
have a European Deposit Insurance Scheme
backed by a European backstop as well
and I believe that will happen
relatively fast so it's interesting we
can be looking at the same eurobarometer
results and draw different conclusions I
am quite concerned about precisely the
animosity that that is being observed in
in Europe there are a number of
questions on trust in the eurobarometer
that one could could see over the past
very volution of the past several years
there is a question on whether European
citizens tend to trust the European
Union as a whole or not whether they
tend to trust the ACB or not very
trapped whether they tend to trust the
european commission or not and the
deterioration in the level of trust of
european citizens in most member states
actually strong weak in most member
states is incredible the trust in the
ECB for example is as low as ever
president right now despite the fact
that you know when I look at European
institutions in the way they have
handled the crisis in my mind the ECB is
the only institution that tried to work
in a more or less European Way putting
politics as much as it could which is
not perfect on the side the European
Commission completely politicized by by
contrast that lack of trust actually is
is all the reasons why I am so concerned
about
about the prospect for the European
Union as a whole we have had a crisis
that has been mishandled and I fear that
it has where serve the prospect for the
European project overall not just the
the year area projecting on on the
behavior of government we have seen in
the last five years I am NOT optimistic
that we will have a true banking Union
in in the euro area other really the
dynamics are such that the government's
who happen to be in the stronger
position try to play with the legal text
so that they can always have the upper
hand for many many many years down the
road and we have seen in the last couple
of years unfortunately the negotiations
confirm this this point so frankly I put
no chances in creating in the euro area
a concept equivalent to the FDIC fed
combination which would be Oh a bank may
be facing some difficulties in Arizona
I'm not going to have the political
parties in Connecticut fight it out and
influence whether the depositors in
Arizona are going to be receiving help
from the ftse or not this is unthinkable
in the in the context of the United
States this is being hardwired in the
negotiations are taking place right now
so that we can still have this wonderful
talk that our European leaders are
giving us a challenger to go and
download from the web some of the
statements out of european council
meetings in directorial every single one
since the beginning of the crisis the
leaders of Europe resolve to do whatever
it takes to protect the European project
that is so incredibly important
for the welfare and for peace in Europe
and they keep repeating that thing and
then we see the decisions they they take
so with a current configuration of
governments I really don't have much
hope we're going to see good solutions
coming up then you say had can you
change the current considering the
current configuration of governments you
would need fundamental political reform
and they're armed with reader it's it's
virtually unthinkable to get a political
reform that would help us to a good
outcome right now just to be clear
thanks let me ask you one very brief
ratification you think that by January 1
2015 the negotiation for the bank union
will collapse or just that they will
approve but they will be banking Union
in name but with no effective bite it's
the ladder the banking Unisource up some
people even thought that even be the
almost suggested it say oh we already
have a greater of banking union of
course it's a banking Union that doesn't
have the FDIC component so it's only me
last round of questions so again we'll
collect two questions Miguel Marin PhD
student in economics and my question is
we have European elections coming up
will that affect what you have been
discussing so far by the banking Union
hello my name is Marie and I'm a student
at the School of International public
affairs my question is regarding the
symmetries between the stronger and the
weaker countries and like stated earlier
the weaker countries have made great
efforts to balance their budget by
decreasing their deficit while strong
countries like Germany continue to run
surpluses and do you see any future
policy or how important do you think it
is for the stronger countries to also
follow the weaker ones and achieving a
more balanced economy very good Massimo
did you want to ask something rich can
you help Massimo get to the microphone
so I like to make a comment related to
the concept of of Union so you mentioned
once I think that the world fiscal Union
as well at the very beginning and I see
the two things a bit connected because
I'm by the way I'm a similarly I'm a
professor of economics and political
science here i forgot to say that so
they're connected in the sense that in
your disagreements i see that or hear
that that there are the two aspects that
are that are separate one is that with
with with the union you know banking
union or fiscal Union you want to
perhaps be able to handle a shock better
than or a crisis better than then Europe
has been able to do before and that part
is where that is where the disagreement
seems to seems to come from because
there is some pessimism about the fact
that the stronger are willing to to
concede more in terms of transfers or
commitment to transfers or contingent
transfers and so on to fix the next
shocked and so that's well that seems to
be where the disagreement is whereas the
other aspect that I don't think has been
covered enough is that a union has a
value in uniformity of of reaction to
for example behavior almost like a
cultural value where a banking Union and
a fiscal Union would have the
possibility to have uniform expected to
create uniform expectations in terms of
what will happen if I do this what will
happen if I'm a firm and I'm doing mmm
and I'm sort of trying to work in the
wiggle room you know in time and not
really not sure what what the regulation
is going to be because the Italian or
the greek banks are are being lenient
and the German one that I have to
interact with because I'm doing
international business is not as lenient
so all this it's not surprising to me
that the first agreements would be in
terms of supervision
and resolution because those things
supervision resolution belong to the
second category of creating uniformity
which is it which is very important but
in its own right even if the pessimist
view on the possibility of of doing also
transfers as as a you know a
compensation and and and and sort of you
know doing what the federal government
in the US would do is impossible so it's
just wonder whether you would agree with
this kind of Dakota me where things you
agree fix it is really good this is the
last one please which one I'll do my
best so Miguel on the issue of the
European elections and banking Union
what's going on in Europe in 2014 goes
much beyond European elections that is
the fact that we have parliamentary
elections means that there will be a new
commission there will be a new president
of the european commission there will be
a new vice president of the european
commission in charge of economic and
financial affairs and then towards the
end of the year we're going to have a
new president of the european council
because the mandate is two and a half
years and likely the way the Eurogroup
operates will change in that context as
well so what we have now in 2014 is an
opportunity to have a change in the
political cycle in europe that includes
the european parliament elections but
goes much beyond European Parliament
elections and that's why the consensus
between Germany and France which is
being built can be leveraged because the
European political cycle is such that it
can incorporate that political impulse
route
quickly now in terms of the
characteristics of the adjustment
process in Europe it is true that
countries that were in deficit have
adjusted quite sharply current account
deficits public deficits have fallen
fallen quite substantially it is true
the Germany had and has a current
account surplus and a general government
surplus clearly the need for adjustment
in creditor countries is recognized as a
matter of principle and as an example
the German Finance Minister Wolfgang
schuble has been on record stating that
increases in wages in Germany are part
of that process of adjustment and so
clearly the need for action by both
surplus and deficit countries is
recognized what we do see however is
that as is usually the case the
adjustment in deficit countries was a
much sharper and as a matter of fact I
believe that every single country that
was under stress has been able to
generate the surplus by now there is I
believe not one single exception Massimo
very quickly on fiscal Union I was asked
a question in a panel in a conference
organised by the International Monetary
Fund in September and the question was
what are the minimal requirements of a
fiscal union necessary for a
well-functioning euro area and basically
what I said is that we need to have the
fist
elements which are necessary for
financial Union to be effective now
that's a very minimal fiscal union in
the following sense since the bank
resolution scheme and the deposit
insurance scheme are fed by
contributions from the financial system
itself and that's the way the system has
been designed one does not need
transfers of any kind what one needs in
a worst-case scenario is breached
financing and the public finance
implications from bridge financing are
relatively limited and so I'm reasonably
confident that a solution for that
relatively minor problem can be solved
at the political level relatively
quickly um yes so my my take briefly on
the european parliament election sir no
I see no chance of influencing any of
the current discussions going on with
regard to the banking Union I should
mention a 1 concern the Fabio test we're
going to see this in May is that we have
in in a large number of the member
states of the European Union the rise of
anti your pian parties and we're going
to see in May just how significant that
rises because if that rise n cept being
significant it may actually compromise
progressing in Europe in a number of
things in a major way for for the
reasons that reason I mentioned so we do
not know that this is the first time
ever where this is a concern which is
again telling us about about how the
European people are thinking about the
progress in in in Europe with regard to
adjustment
more symmetric adjustment frankly you
can never force someone how to consume
or if they want to save more we've never
managed to do that so we'll always have
this asymmetry in there in the
adjustment and I think we will always
continue to have the asymmetry in this
adjustment the issue is whether we have
automatic mechanisms that make the
adjustment smoother and less painful and
this is what could be done if we had a
fiscal Union I'll to to bring it back to
that question going forward we could
think of many elements the fiscal you
think who think about just a partial
common funding of unemployment insurance
benefits is that a fiscal Union does
that involve transfers or is it simply
the broadening apple and insurance
mechanism oh when we think about
insurance is that a transfer mechanism
or is that really a mechanism that yes
it does transfer resources from some
individuals to other individuals in a
contingency something goes bad so it
depends really on how you look how you
look at things I think that we can
improve the insurance aspects of of what
governments do without going in the
direction of engineering permanent
transfers from one member state to
another member state that is something
that I do not foresee at all and frankly
I would not agree with a design like
that I don't think it would be it would
be good for your being in that direction
I'm going to end by saying that I agree
with them with veto that we don't really
need to depend the fiscal Union to
stabilize a big part of the problem if
we complete the banking Union we are
going to do a lot better
going forward when I'm thinking about
the fdic I view the FDIC has just an
insurance device I don't i do not see
the FDIC as part of the fiscal mechanism
of the United States at all and this is
how we would like to design their the
deposit guarantee a resolution facility
in in Europe as well it should be
industry funded as a matter of fact I
think that you may not even need to have
a backstop from the stage because if you
think about it the ability to tax future
deposits everywhere in Europe for
everyone in the euro area and the
monopoly to that taxation is enough to
give you a good credit rating and the
ability to borrow if you do not have the
resources that you may need in order to
to help out resulting a bank or bank
deposit guarantee somewhere so I don't
view that it's a fiscal operation and I
think that that's it's very important
way to go some of those who oppose going
in the direction even suggest that that
the creation of this insurance scheme is
a physical operation and then and then
opposed to it because they do not wish
to to advance anything that that would
depend fiscally the European Union
terrific let me thank everyone for
coming and especially thank our speakers
Peter Gaspar nathalyz or four knees
thank you very much
you